Hello!
Ms. Coffee Bean and her team of archaeologists
discovered
an ancient Machine Learning paper
and the finding is interesting for 3 reasons:
Firstly, the paper solves a part of symbolic
mathematics with deep neural networks, surpassing
even the mighty Mathematica on the test set.
Secondly, it is not really self-supervised
learning, but yet the amount of training data
for this task is virtually infinite, stick
around to see why and thirdly, it is one of
Ms. Coffee Bean’s favorite papers.
I think she has a weak spot for mathematics,
hihi…
So, welcome to this AI Coffee Break
where you will find out
how artificial intelligence
tackles symbolic mathematics!
Deep learning can do symbolic mathematics,
or at least a part of it as far as this paper
goes, but why should anybody care about this?
Well, you should be hyped because of at least
two reasons:
First, mathematics follows rigorous rules
and is exact.
Perhaps you remember that e to the power of
x integrated is again e to the power of x
plus a constant and nothing else would be
the answer here.
But deep learning with its neural networks
is clearly statistical, which can be seen
as an opposite to rule-based systems, where
you could prove that you arrive at the right
answer 100% of the time.
One more reason to care about neural networks
solving symbolic mathematics is exactly the
symbolic nature of this problem:
Neural networks had huge success on domains
where representations are continuous in the
first place, like in computer vision where
pixels take continuous values.
Dark spots take low values, while bright pixels
have large values.
But while neural networks perform
well on continous problems,
they are still struggling with symbolic reasoning,
so with exactly the mathematical equations
this paper deals with, which are in forms
like x + y, which could
stand for any two numbers being added up.
While the numerical expression is continuous,
as there are several other numbers between
2 and 3, x and y are the opposite of continuous,
they are symbols that can
stand for numbers
or even for other symbols, and there is nothing
in between the symbol x and the symbol y,
so to say.
The only relationship defined here is stated
in the equation, but that’s about it.
And neural networks so far, had been applied
on numeric tasks where the network gets as
input two numbers and the output is again
a number, like adding or multiplying two numbers,
and there they perform quite poorly.
But this paper considers the
symbolic type of calculations where the input
is an equation describing the relationship
of symbols and the output is again in symbolic
form, but this time, representing the solution.
And if you remember from mathematics classes,
depicted here is integration.
Another symbolic mathematics problems are first
and second order ordinary differential equations
or short ODEs.
Ms. Coffee Bean thinks that it is here, in
the problem choice where the genius of the
paper is condensed.
For this video, we will stick with the integration
since we want to stay at a beginner level
and ODEs are renowned to scare people.
For everyone interested in ODEs, check out
the paper linked in the video description.
Disclaimer: it works very similar to integration.
So, we think we agree that both integration
and ODEs are hard for humans and now we want
to solve symbolic integration with neural
networks.
But neural networks require training data,
so pairs of functions and their integrals.
Where to get that from?
We could generate some functions randomly
and take systems like MATLAB and Mathematica
to predict the integral.
But these systems are not very fast and sometimes
fail even for integrable functions, so forward
generation is a good start for some training
data, but won’t get us far and we want to
be better than Mathematica.
Therefore, a little out-of-the-box thinking
is required.
Integration is hard, but the backward operation
to it, is differentiation.
Which is fast, easy to compute, following
simple rules.
So let’s use this lesson
and additionally to forward generation use
something else: by generating random functions
on the output side instead of the input side
and then computing their derivatives.
These function pairs can be then added to
the training pool.
This is cool and it’s called backward generation
and it can generate a lot of hard examples,
but has the following problem:
It is very unlikely to randomly generate very
complicated examples in the first place and
even more unlikely is to have them simplify
to a very simple function in the derivative.
It is important to have
these long-short combinations
too, otherwise the network could become biased
to long equations.
To address this, the authors use another clever
trick: two random functions F and G are generated,
their derivatives small f and small g
are computed and these pairs
are added to the training set.
But now, with the rule of integration by parts,
one can also add to the training set combinations
of these f and g functions like this: F times
G is already known because it is already in
the training set, only that the second term
is unknown.
We know small f and the integral of g, but
we do not know the integral of f times G,
BUT with enough luck it might already be in
the training set if this already contains
a lot of stuff generated with forward and
backward generation beforehand!
So every time the authors discover something
like this in the training set, they generate
a new data point by backward generation with
integration by parts.
But Ms. Coffee Bean, wait a little: The authors
have now three means of generating as much
training data as they want with forward and
backward generation,
also using integration by parts.
But all this relies on randomly generating
functions which are then either integrated
or differentiated.
So three questions remain:
How to generate functions randomly,
and how to feed them into a neural network?
And what is this mysterious neural network
anyway?
Okay, we will answer
these questions one at a time.
To randomly generate functions, we first need
a way to represent mathematical expressions.
The choice here falls to trees where operators
and functions are internal nodes, the operands
are children and constants and variables are
leaves.
The choice falls to trees because of lots
of reasons: Trees represent the order in which
operations are executed.
Associativity is clear and parentheses become
obsolete.
And because of this, they are very easy to
grow.
On the other hand, expanding expressions in
the sequential representation, is very
clear at the both ends, but adding something
in between might get a little messy.
So yeah, if one wants to grow an expression
randomly, one just has to randomly select
functions, operators and operands randomly
and just check that unary operands, like
sinuses or exponentials get only one child,
while binary operands like
addition or multiplication
get two children.
Then on to the second question: How to process
mathematical expressions, now in form of trees,
by a neural network?
Well, we don’t process the trees.
Wait, what?
The authors linearize the trees to a sequence
again by using prefix notation where each
node is written before its children, from
left to right, like in this example.
The advantage over the common way of writing
mathematical expressions is that the prefix
notation does not require any parentheses
which would make the life of the neural network
harder by having to remember to close them
after they have been opened.
So no trees?
Neural networks working on trees where very
en vogue in Natural Language Processing (NLP),
see Tree-LSTMs.
But now, NLP is dominated by Transformers
and guess what: The neural network employed
to solve symbolic integration and ODEs is
a Transformer!
Haha, you did not expect that to happen, right?
Transformers are now everywhere.
So yeah, the authors use
a transformer architecture
to translate from the input sequence to the
output sequence.
And with the awesome data generation procedure
that can generate virtually infinite amounts
of it, there is enough data for the transformer
to learn the problem.
It does not really matter
that symbolic integration
is hard (I think we all agree here), because
there is enough data, which proves to be
in this case 20 million examples.
Yeah, they generated 20 million data samples,
just like that.
This is why Ms. Coffee Bean
thinks that this is genius.
Take this equation: You want to maximize research
results.
You know transformers can do anything, so
of course you use them.
You have your problem but you realize its
limited data is too little for the transformer
to learn something meaningful.
But you still want to do good research.
So you choose an application where you have
virtually infinite amounts of data and the
recipe to maximizing success is set!
Well, don't take Ms. Coffee Bean so seriously,
but it seems like this is kind of the recipe
for success nowadays.
And this is what partially
happens in self-supervised
learning because there you have almost infinite
amounts of training data.
So yeah, in any case, the 20 million samples
that the authors here have, seem to be very
effective, because their transformer network
is able to solve the integration examples
with around 99% accuracy in less than a second
per example, while Mathematica (given 30
seconds of compute time) can only solve 84
percent, Maple 67 percent and
Matlab only 65 percent.
But where are the remaining 1 percent
in integration performance of the Transformer?
Well, we remember that we are in the statistical
world of neural networks.
So, until we meet you next time, watch out
for outliers if you wander
out alone in this world…!
And hey, do not forget to like and subscribe!
Okay bye!